and that's really important I think when
we start to think about how are we
possibly gonna heal fast enough because
right now the numbers say we can't our
sperm counts as a species have dropped
from you know fifty seven percent in
just the last three decades one in three
males is infertile if we we're
continuing this trajectory there's no
flattening so you know we passed four
we're just another three or four decades
and suddenly ninety percent of males are
infertile our species is collapsing
meanwhile children in the United States
now fifty two percent of them are
diagnosed with a chronic disease before
they're 18 one in three children will
have autism by 2035 one eighty percent
of adults will have cancer by that same
time period and so there's literally no
way we can turn this boat around fast
enough biologically but all of that is
the past and what is more important is
right this second and if you and I can
modify each other's genome right now in
a more profound way than any of our
pasts could have done then it would
suggest that our past doesn't actually
matter other than a learning experience
history is there to demonstrate what not
to do if we keep taking history and
printing it on the future we will simply
disappear off the surface of the planet
which will be good for the biology on
earth and when we disappear finally just
saying that it's like if if all the
plants and animals disappeared we would
die if we died all the plants and
animals would flourish we recovered some
perspective I mean opal is a great
example of that humans have to move out
of Chernobyl over those last and four
and a half decades since that massive
nuclear Iran beautiful most huge
explosion of diversity wolves are back
and the Bulls are thriving in that
radioactive soil Mother Earth is back to
thriving in still the most contaminated
corner of the planet Mother Earth
couldn't care less
mother earth designed uranium you don't
think she knows how to deal with that
stuff well I definitely believe in that
as far as like if we are biological
beings and there's a viola and there's a
problem there's a there's a fix that's
the balance of the universe that's the
balance of the world it's like oh it
must be a law I'm sure there's some kind
of law for that but there I really truly
believe that we just don't know what it
is right we
you know I eat you know cordyceps and
reishi and lion's mane and I love eating
mushrooms but look I've clearly not
covered a lot of the mushrooms so are
four million arguments so that's about
it so you know when you think about that
giant perspective like that giant
perspective of how much there is out
there that we don't know about there is
a hundred percent believe there's a cure
out there that we don't have to pump
ourselves with synthetics and things
that nearly kill us to kill what we're
trying to get rid of there is a fix
there's a biological fix and I think
that fix at that biologic level is very
similar to that kind of wireless
communication network that we just
talked about on the IT side I'm going to
stop perturbing the cell-cell
communication of human beings at the
same time that we stop and perturbing
the cell-cell communication down in our
soils then everything in between will
fix itself and so what are we doing to
our soils today and this speaks to that
hyper intelligence of Mother Nature is
that today we are poisoning Mother Earth
with about six billion pounds of
chemical herbicides and pesticides
annually more than time Charles do you
blew in on that crop I mean there's
pretty it's pretty understood that
they're spraying things in the air well
I mean you take an airplane you're
spraying things in the air it's called
fossil fuels right sure there's just
that simple one simple thing it's just
the airplane or if there's you know
geoengineering going on which is pretty
well described by the point sources
they're seeding clouds there's even
anything where you can get up you can
you can guarantee a wedding without rain
yeah what geoengineering enough spending
you can change that weather for a
hundred thousand dollars you can
guarantee no rain on your wedding day
you